luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys welcome back to the
lehigh pen show it is powered of course by icon
plus capital the vc firm aubry great to have
you how you doing today i'm doing well thanks
for having me on leah i'm so excited we haven't
talked yeah i know i'm really excited to jump
in before we do i just want to let everybody
know that this is um sponsored by blockfi so
you can actually get up to 250 when you sign up
um which is pretty great right now because i mean
everything is crashing so a little bit of money
there isn't too bad um but yeah aubry how are
you doing where are you based right now so right
now i'm not my normal setup um obviously i think
i film all the tv from like my house i'm at my
grandmother's shore house in new jersey in like
southern new jersey that's why it's very humid and
crazy down here but um yeah it's i don't know if
you know like the jersey shore i mean they used
to have like a show about it but it's not i know
it's not like the show at all people like like
just a bunch of like italians like fist pumping
the whole time it's not that at all but oh it's
not that like that's what we think it is in the uk
it's not that it's actually really nice like
short tap and it's gotten like a bad rap i'm
sure there's like parts of like the uk that people
like chalk up to some sort of like stereotype and
it's like absolutely nothing like that but yeah
anyways down here fixing up my grandmother's house
and working at the same time right now nice well
i kind of want to go into all of this stuff i mean
i know that you know the markets are crashing
right now and we'll get into that but i want
to talk a little bit about you how you got into
crypto um i really love what you do i think it's
really different it's so current and i also love
try lolly the brand that you've built so i want
to go back a little bit um and on san francisco
how did you get into crypto then how did you land
with tri lolly so crypto i got into back in 2016
and it was sort of just right out of college i was
looking to be a journalist i was um kind of trying
to figure out what i wanted to do with my life and
i did political pr and then sort
of found this company that was
doing crypto pr and before that like maybe a few
months before that i had been personally investing
in crypto bitcoin ethereum litecoin just you
know sort of like the top of the coin market cap
but wait before before you got into crypto you
were actually investing yeah i was investing
well i mean before i worked in crypto like
maybe three months i was sort of investing
and i had roommates and friends and people that
were like very like had gone full into crypto
and so i started to follow them because they were
actually working in financial services and if they
were sort of looking towards this new asset class
it was probably a signal of things changing and
so i think i bought my first bitcoin actually at
a bitcoin atm down in which is usually not where
someone buys their first bitcoin which is very
funny um at bitcoin atm down in like the lower
side of manhattan they have this atm machine and
i and i bought there and then most of the i bought
on exchanges but yeah that's been that's been the
beginning so i've been in this space for about
five years and then with lolly i had a friend
uh he's still my friend his name's louis and he
connected me with alex and said you need to talk
to alex he's really building something great here
and i worked on a lot of projects that i thought
were too early for where the market was and when i
heard about lolly i was i said this is a great
entry point and i you just know when you hear a
winner like you're like this is going to work
i very much believe in this and it's needed
and so that's sort of the background there and i
guess i should probably explain lolly to people
who yeah where um so lolly is a bitcoin rewards
company that gives you free bitcoin when you shop
online from over a thousand merchants and it's
only in the us right now but we're going to
expand internationally so these are places like
macy's priceline harry's chewy and you can earn
free bitcoin on every purchase so it's a
way to passively invest in bitcoin and own
the asset without sort of feeling the hurt
sometimes if you're putting your own money
into it uh so it's good for newbies it's good for
people who've been in this space for a long time
and i've sort of saw the way that i think alex
beautifully put it one time is we've seen these
different ways of waves of adoption we've
seen uh mining obviously the original way to
procure bitcoin and then people buying on
exchanges which was like more of the 2017
cycle and then there's sort of another wave that's
come through and it's it's a newer sort of uh
retail investor that just wants exposure to the
asset but they don't know if they really want to
put money into it and that's through earnings so
it's sort of the third way of the wave of bitcoin
adoption through lolly yeah i think it's really
cool i think it's it's really different to kind of
regard it as a new wave of bitcoin mass adoption
because it's just not something which i think
is an obvious play really is it because you
know we always talk about like education but
i think the best way to get to give anybody
anything or to get them on board is to give
them something for free like i am a huge fan of
crypto.com and i have their card but i i never
put the money down or anything somebody that i
worked with was like leia you need to get on board
so just here it is you know and i think
i think that's the best way to do it but
what you've done with um trilogy is so interesting
because i feel like you really tap into um the
culture the online culture and i think that it's
it's not just like a fun game it's actually like
a really smart business strategy so what would you
say some of the key things are to growing a brand
online i like what you said there because i think
people sometimes not saying everyone thinks this
sees memes in the way people have run accounts
as sort of a joke and it's it's silly and you're
not taking seriously when it's actually very
calculated and it's obviously done for reasons of
course we want to have a good time we're not you
know sitting back here calculating every single
meme that we put out on the on the channel but
there's a lot of sort of old age traditional which
is sort of like you know revolting against the old
way of media the old way of connecting with your
consumers is being so professional and uptight
and buttoned up and that's sort of not the way
the world is anymore so things are shifting
financially but also the way companies market
and um sorry just not on tandem there because i i
no go for it but um what was the original question
how do we yeah so i basically i'm asking how do
you um how important is that to growing a brand or
like what would you say the most important thing
is to growing a brand i know because i'm saying
like you guys obviously focus on the meme culture
quite a bit um so how so what would you say the
key features are to growing a brand online and
growing a presence um online yeah i where we were
we started in 2018 and so that's a bear market and
people really are just looking for entertainment
and i think there's a lot of people now creators
that are doing a great job of this and it wasn't
really prevalent in the crypto community because
you kind of have to get over this hump of trust
with a lot of financial institutions before you
you know you lolly is a custodian in many ways and
you know we hold a lot of bitcoin and but we come
up we approach the uh customer in a different way
than you know some other financial institutions
but now you see exchanges sort of behaving in
a similar manner you the way binance is running
their account it's they sort of like everyone's
sort of just copied off of like sort of the lolly
model in a way they're like it is okay to make
jokes online especially because a lot of crypto
is sort of a joke sometimes not like not the
assets but some of the i mean some of the
names of these tokens are absolutely insane and
the things that go on with elon musk or whatever
if you're not staying culturally relevant on
these topics you're losing a great opportunity
to communicate with a large amount of people
and so i think that people have begun to realize
these a lot realize this and a lot of um exchanges
and companies in the crypto space have adopted it
but it was not a thing this was not a thing for
companies for a while but yeah the the lolly brand
should the reason we we make it so uh comfortable
and fun and whatever you want to call
it is because it should be you know
bitcoin should be approachable it should feel
that way you want to feel good about the brand
when you go and use the product you you want to
feel like you want to shop online and get bitcoin
back so it's all these things to encourage it
through the name through the branding the color
it's like a periwinkle purple you know things that
weren't traditionally done or used in the space so
i think the combination of all those things
make it more likeable and it's called lolly
it was never taking itself very seriously in the
first place but you can take yourself seriously
in the same token if that makes sense yeah no i
think it does and i think that um it's just really
interesting because there is a huge shift in the
way that we do things and i think that really
started with our generation um you know we were
kind of just i guess it's because social media
social media made things far more informal which
meant that moving into the workplace things sort
of became more informal and i just think it's
like a slow kind of evolution um you know it's
just so it's just so interesting to see and like
it's particularly with crypto because everything
is alternative like when this thing started you
had major billionaires and ceos doing interviews
and t-shirts and there was no formality from the
beginning um and i think that really like annoyed
some people and maybe it's just like a tech thing
as well because mark zuckerberg back in the day
you know would turn up and t-shirts maybe it's
a tech thing it's a little bit of a tech thing
i think but i think crypto's taking it to the next
level there's always that you know i think a lot
of people come over from the wall street side of
things they still wear like the suits and whatever
but mostly you're seeing a shift a generational
shift on a lot of different areas through finance
through the way you communicate the way people
work and so it's all sort of happening right now
and it was probably pushed uh pushed through and
like faster i guess because of coco because people
had to be kind of less formal and you couldn't
go into an office and all those things so uh
people are learning that rather quickly but you
say something really interesting about the suit
okay so i i don't i've seen all the name names and
keep it professional but i did interview somebody
recently no never i get to meet somebody recently
and he was like in a full-blown suit and it
was actually the first time in over a year i'd
interviewed somebody who was in a full-blown suit
and even my editor said to me i didn't trust him
i go do you know what it's the suit that's why
you didn't trust him i'm serious i'm absolutely
serious it's because you're not used to it and
everybody's so informal and like you said it's
about like being relatable and creating something
which doesn't scare people off like who wears
a suit in crypto anymore that's true i actually
would that's funny because there's this there's
this social experiment of you know if someone is
hurt on the sidewalk and they're wearing a suit
would you go help them rather than someone who's
not wearing a suit and that looks you know maybe
you know kind of whatever i don't know um and so
that but now if you flip that around and say you
know if you're interviewing someone or you're
they're coming for a job or you're just meeting
them are they wearing a suit or not it does put
people in a weird mindset like put off sometimes
this is like too serious of a conversation um
that's like i guess that's just the boomers i
don't know yeah he was a boomer but like i think
what's also really interesting is before i started
to be more independent in the space the first
crypto company i worked for did everything the
traditional way it was so formal and so uptight
and unfortunately the company didn't succeed and
i think that's the problem i think that's why
i think that's all though is that the uk do
you feel like the uk because i lived in it
wasn't a uk company it wasn't an american american
company okay so i worked in dublin not an island
not a part of the uk but um it for a few months
and i felt like the office that i worked in and
everyone there was so dressed up all the
time lovely people lovely bunch very great
so dressed up all the time like wearing suits
every day to the office and this was two years
ago that i was working there and it was a crypt
it was crypto company but very very dressed up
and it was just odd to me none of that made sense
we're working on with crypto clients uh anyway so
no i'm with you yeah no no i'm definitely sorry
i can't hear you like i thought this was an irish
thing maybe and i don't know no i think i think i
think it's just like an office thing if i'm honest
um i think it's an office kind of thing but so
okay so i want to get your thoughts on why what
do you think so effective about it so it's
obviously relatable but i kind of had this
whole idea in my head and i made this video and i
was sort of comparing it to like finance in terms
of like supply and demand and i had this theory
that there's a real lack of like happiness and
entertainment in this world and so i felt people
would gravitate towards things which are lighter
and funnier and sillier um what do you think i
for yeah there's been a bunch of financial meme
accounts that have basically popped up over the
past few years and it's this shared struggle and
strife that traditional finances throughout but
then cryptos crypto memes have been around for a
long time uh the enter the community is also just
more plugged in online than other communities so
they're they're always online they're day trading
and so they can make memes they understand culture
and for that's more on the community side but for
a company side really a meme is just a message
that you're getting across in a in a shorter way
and especially on twitter you have a character
limit and you can only really get out what people
can get in in probably a second scroll down
their timeline so whatever you have to say
it needs to be funny needs to be convincing
it needs to or evoke some sort of emotion get
something across or else your meme's not good
so people like like i said people are downplaying
how what a strategy it is but if you go look on
instagram now there's a lot of companies that are
sort of hiding their product within memes yeah
you feel like you're reading a meme and it's funny
but it's secretly branded and you wouldn't know it
unless you sort of really looked into it and
you see that their products at the end but
the content is so good that you're willing
to share it and the real metric used to be
likes and uh retweets or just likes on instagram
but really it's the shared button or the saved
button on instagram and that's what we found so
we run a meme account on lolly's instagram and
every day we rank the best bitcoin memes and if
we look at i've looked at the metrics of it the
the amount of shares that it got the
last one we just did roasted elon musk
is crazy people love memes they love to share
they love to send it to their friends i'm sure
you do when you're on instagram or some you
know you find a funny meme you want to share it
and the engagement is so much higher compared to
something that would just be promoting your brand
if that makes sense you're still yeah they're
still coming they're coming for the content
yeah and i think i actually don't think it's
anything too new um because i think what they're
selling you is a lifestyle and i believe that's
always been the case when it comes to advertising
like you can watch the most incredible ad on tv
right it's so good and then you're like what on
earth are they advertising and then right at
the end mcdonald's you know so so they're so
they're selling you you know like a lifestyle
and a community and i guess memes is the same
thing it's just done differently but in terms of
meme coins this is something that you know has
totally blown up recently so you've been in the
space longer that i have so i want to get your
thoughts um things like doge and safe moon yeah
safe moon shiba inu and all those fun cute things
um is this is it is this just standard bull market
or is this part of this evolving internet culture
i think a lot of it is the bull market did you
see the one i saw it last night little zam the
rapper came out with pubecoin did you see that
so i saw somebody was about to do a live stream
i saw someone's about to do a live stream
and i was like wait wait wait i'm confused
so what was that yeah i i didn't look
into the token economics or whatever
that pube is but uh you know little zan put
out and that's when i was like i need to
close my laptop and and get off twitter for
the day which is obviously impossible but
uh yeah these these tokens ass yummy
safe moon i think there's there are
some tokens and there's some protocols
are being made that have some promise but
not not all of these i think they're going
to fall away you know by the wayside the way
that the sort of ico is happened i can't even
name anything that's really around anymore and
even that during that time i was pretty young and
new to the space i could even tell with literal
no experience and experience at all in the space
that this was a was just not the ico market was
like a bubble and there was no cap icos and
then they just rebranded to stos and then
where are these projects today what have they
done four years later there's nothing for most
of them some of the tokens are around um that
were created then but i i can only name a few so
i do think a lot of it is the bull market but i
do think that there is a lot of creators that are
finding ways to optimize payments and and they're
trying to figure it out i don't think anyone
has it perfectly nailed down or trying to figure
out the ecosystem but when i was out in l.a there
is so many celebrities and people that are
interested in in basically creating their own
coin or creating their own crypto project they're
very into crypto which is interesting because i'm
always in new york and the crypto conversation in
new york is a lot different than the creator uh
culture conversation that's in la so it's sort of
dynamic in the united states right now i would say
yeah my brother's actually been
spending the last three months in la
um he's a big tick tocker or whatever um
and yeah we'll talk about that another time
anyway he is like so into crypto everybody in
la all the creators i'm hearing are holding doge
um they are all like he's got his own yacht which
is if if anyone doesn't know the yat is when you
have the emojis which belongs to you so like a
phone number but it like belongs to you and it
can't be replaced i mean it can't be copied nobody
else can have that that combination of emojis
um i think he's actually going to miami and
i'm supposed to be there but he's getting to go
there you know so he's really in the miami bitcoin
conference there's another one there's an nft one
around the same time so he's gonna go to that one
also on the same day um yeah it's insane but like
speaking of doge okay um this one's really
interesting elon musk has backed it so i just
want to get your your thoughts on it the way i
kind of where i stand on this i think most people
know is that i'm obviously very aware it's a [
__ ] coin it's a meme coin and it has no value
like i've always been very open about that um but
what i do but i predicted that elon musk would try
to work with so-called developers
to make it something and i'm just
i'm intrigued to see what happens i don't
know what are your thoughts on on dage
i have a lot of thoughts on just elon musk in
general and and why he operates the way he does
and i think that people react very
emotionally to what he does every day online
and he's he's a little unhinged do you
think i think a little bit i think he
there are some parallels to the way elon not
to make it political tweets but and trump it's
i knew you're gonna say that i was way far it's
just a little bit of like and not quite to that
extent dave portnoy dave tries to be sort of
on that level but his is like a little bit more
contrived because he's always he has a production
team that really puts stuff out there whereas
trump and elon just really shoot from the hip on
all their tweets you know that they were just sort
of thought out of five seconds before they went
out and so do i think it's a pr stunt i mean tesla
was profitable on you know in q1 mostly because
of adding bitcoin to their balance sheet and so
yeah i in in some ways i do think he's going to
perhaps sell a little bit by low you know i could
see that happening i also see that the community
has really pissed him off like i think the fight
that went on last week was insane you know he
really people were can be awful online i think
elon probably has tough skin but the like absolute
crying from grown men online it's just ridiculous
you don't need a hero to champion your coin
you don't need a mascot this is not why we got
into the space i'm so sick of hearing people cry
because it you know the price dipped five percent
now it's like literally fifty percent or i don't
even know where we were from the market top but
you know there are there are worse problems in
the world and i get it's just funny meaning and
and all of that and elon's wrong a lot about you
know a lot of information he's putting out there
so people want to explain why there are you know
renewable energy resources for mining and a lot
of that is being done but at the same time you
know you're giving attention to a screaming child
at a point and you got you got to know and to pull
back in my opinion so you just like can't give him
all the attention it would be so much funnier
if people just ignored it could you imagine
i totally agree with you i think that um i think
so firstly it was so complicated what went on
because i definitely agree the first main issue
is is just spreading the fud about you know
the environmental concerns when it comes to
bitcoin that was so unneeded and i understand
you know i think peter mccormack was saying that
a lot of bitcoin has spent a lot of time debunking
all of this and for somebody to come out with so
much influence to basically echo all that all that
misinformation i get it it's horrible and and
and all that stuff but it just it went too far
and you know if bitcoin there's so much wrong
here so like it's supposed to be decentralized
and it is decentralized but then one man
shouldn't be able to move the markets like that
exactly i totally agree with that and i think
that's a problem if it can be moved i also think
the bitcoiners some of the people in the community
that were screaming and yelling and crying
it's almost like in pr what i teach or
like what i've sometimes if there's a
problem a crisis comes problem you know
something's happening to a company and
you know you don't want to bring attention
to it almost talking about the issue
and continuing to acknowledge it brings more bad
press to the issue because there's a lot of people
that probably didn't really you know care outside
of the crypto community i know maybe they didn't
see it maybe they didn't even see it exactly and
so but then it gets exacerbated by the community
because they throw a you know an absolute fit for
three days and so then i mean story and it's and
i don't think people understand how that works you
give you add fuel to the fire it becomes a battle
elon musk versus everyone dogecoin versus bitcoin
you know and then it goes on fox news and people
are talking about it and that's on fox fox
business they've been covering everything cnbc and
that is how the stories get made where
as if you would have just ignored
perhaps elon and he just said he had some
environmental concerns and you know a few
people talked about it it probably wouldn't have
been as good so i think sometimes the community
and there's nothing you can do about it because
there's so many people part of this community now
can get so riled up about everything you
know and it's not always beneficial for
for you know the media coverage the the community
a lot of things but like back to your point one
person should not be able to influence a market
yeah really and so i think that you know that
still is a high concern for many people and
so i think that's worth sort of realizing now
um but the dip today you know i'm not sure even
anyone knows why it's stipping so much at this
point you said perhaps china yeah i keep hearing
about china um but okay so do you think that
do you think he was doing some some kind of pr
stunt here or do you think his actual concerns
were genuine because this is a smart man and i've
said the same thing about donald trump like i've
always said donald trump is a genius yeah and
people always say he's an idiot but he's not and
you know elon musk is obviously really intelligent
guy how do you buy bitcoin not know about the
environmental concerns um and then and then
say no we won't take we won't accept it anymore
meanwhile you're launching rockets to the moon
yeah which is not environmentally friendly so
did he know yeah i mean the carbon footprint
for every single rocket that goes out is
you know i think there's some stat how many trips
around the earth but i thought you were going to
give me i thought you're going to give me a stat
there i was excited i know nothing off the top of
my head unfortunately i'm not an energy expert
but i did read that uh i mean there are tesla's
a publicly traded company they have lawyers they
do due diligence they they would have to look into
unless things run a lot differently and they can
you can think about these companies um i don't
know if this is off a little bit it feels like the
camera is like no you're good matched up with me
okay there's a there's a lot of companies that you
think are run super efficiently and you peel back
the you know the veil and you're like oh wow it's
not actually run as well as you think it is that
would be hard to imagine at tesla because i do
think alaska is very smart he's been successful
uh if he has environmental concerns maybe
he does uh but the way i'm seeing comms run
at tesla i mean he put out a note statement
that wasn't even a press release it was on it
was on like a notebook but isn't that what we were
saying earlier though isn't that just like part of
the new style to be more relatable and not seem
so distant and formal when you have shareholders
though you have to you have to put out a press
release because you have to buy people so there's
actually a protocol with press releases and
when you de-list or change change anything
you're supposed to let people know because
they're publicly traded and there's regulation
with you know public trade companies but since he
didn't actually sell any of the bitcoin supposedly
um i that's just taunting the market then at
that point and just causing controversy and
to be honest his whole backing behind doge i
don't like does he actually want to accept that
as payment for space like i do i believe it yeah
i do you really and then what does that become
and then it becomes a serious point okay listen
right i could be wrong doge's is a piece of
paper because i saw you i saw you put out a tweet
about this i want you to explain the tweets yeah i
you were like which tweet i've done so many it
was about elon uh accepting doge as like a space
token or was like being the you know currency
of mario okay so this is why this is where i
look at it like this guy is a narcissist
okay this guy wants to be the best thing
he has totally revolutionized the the way that
we we transact right he he started paypal that's
incredible crypto aside um you know spacex spacex
is insane like if we just take a second to think
about it you know i actually remember your a tweet
that you made um i don't know why i remember it
but i just remember it when when it went to the
moon no she went to sorry and go to me when i
went to when it went up to space you tweeted i
can't believe you know an individual has done this
you know on their own i remember you tweeted it
right i was like yeah she's like yeah she's right
isn't that just like insane so what he's done is
is unbelievable and i'm getting a kind of energy
that he doesn't want to be part of a movement like
he wants his own movement okay like bitcoin isn't
his bitcoin is everyone's and bitcoin belongs to
bitcoin belongs to the og's and it's everyone's
okay like he isn't the father of bitcoin michael
saylor right now has been able to become like
this so self-proclaimed god elon musk would have
to take second seat to that i really don't think
that's what he wants i really think it comes from
a narcissistic place like he called himself the
doge father he wants to be king of whatever is
coming next and so he has the power the influence
and the intelligence to make something now i'm not
saying it's going to replace bitcoin this is where
everybody kind of like misunderstood bitcoin is
bitcoin i'm not saying he's going to replace it
bitcoin is still that store of value but right
now bitcoin isn't great when it comes to being
that global medium of exchange like it's just
not um it's a and don't talk about the lightning
network that might work in some places but it's
it's am i'm using like network nodes the majority
of people i know use it no um so i can imagine he
creates this internet currency like we understand
crypto is borderless okay that's fantastic
but we need it to be cheap like i'm sorry
but like i i get paid mostly in bitcoin but one
of the companies i work with they just pay me a
little bit of money and it sometimes i should just
do it in bitcoin cash so we just do it in litecoin
because otherwise we're wasting too much money
yeah so we need something and we need it now and
this is what i was getting to i'm sort of saying
like the lightning network like bitcoin came one
time but the lightning network is too late yes we
need something now and so i feel like elon musk is
trying to fill that hole now so i agree with the
narcissism at that point you know i think you make
a really good point i think it's it comes from not
a genuine place or wherever it comes from an ego
like that needs to be you know and there's a lot
of ceos and men out there that feel like they have
done that and trump had a huge ego too like he can
be smart and sort of an opportunistic person who
ca you know capitalize basically on like a group
of people who needed a leader at a time and so
elon has a very cult following and they'll
follow him to like the ends of the earth
that are not in crypto and some that are in
crypto and so i agree i think he he sort of did
no one's late to bitcoin but he's not no g he
he he came in did he he first bought in february
it was right after the example it was the day
after the super bowl that he announced i remember
and so i mean announcing in 2021 it was cool
he was a hero for a second but yeah he wants to
lead a revolution not just sort of join
and so there's a lot of other you know
who knows what goes on in that brain but um and
especially i mean the fact that he took the snl
bit that also like lends itself to the argument
that he's an absolute narcissist because like
he is like who goes on like a tech ceo going
on snl unheard of like stephen i mean what no
absolutely and i also think like okay there's it's
one thing revolutionizing the world okay but it's
another thing being the person that does that like
that is something else you know being the person
behind paypal being the person behind spacex
like there's something else the argument then
like why not create his own coin why get behind
doge if that like again we know he's been pumping
like why doesn't he just do his own okay so from
what i've read and this is like really really like
brief is that it would be very difficult because
there would be a lot of regulatory issues because
of tesla and everything it would just be very
very difficult um he can and i think if he can't
make doge to the if he can't get doge to where
he wants it to be he will make his own coin
so i think doge is his first is his first
thing but i then just skip doge because like
the gamble of trying to get everyone then you get
everyone like then you get all these doge holders
toddlers out there and like you have to basically
transition them to a new coin it seems like just
trim the fat make your own coin and call it
a day and get that going because by the time
you ever get to mars you get to that point
i feel like you'd want that coin ready and
trading but whatever i don't know what he's up
to i it's honestly just so annoying i just want
to mute his name also the fact that fighting with
a man named elon is just like the funniest thing
to me no jabs at his name but it's
just like fighting elon all day i know
from a pr perspective um i remember who tweeted
it maybe it was like his name's jack sparrow or
something on that tonight he said this is like
a really he said this is like a really bad move
and i was sort of like what are you talking about
nobody outside of crypto knows what's going on he
can he can [ __ ] on bitcoin but like nobody knows
um why he's actually wrong nobody cares about
you know bitcoin mining being geographically
independent i mean do you really think this was
a bad pr move i just don't even think it matters
i think that the is actually a great opportunity
i think nick carter did a great job of explaining
a lot of the you know the research done behind
proof of work and i think yeah a lot of people
think that the transactions you are using the
most energy when it's actually the mining uh
that is so there's this idea that oh wow every
time i send a transaction or a remittance to
my family across seas that i'm using a large
amount of energy and i think debunking that
fact and just talking about how people it you
know it's it's advantageous for miners to look for
renewables on their end you know of course well as
you know why why would they want to rack up a
crazy electric bill when they could install solar
panels and and do whatever they can to make it
easier for them so i think that that's really hard
again the ma the main conversation of people out
there they probably don't understand that or care
to understand that they just need to know the
facts so really on a pr end it's really giving
people bullet points of this is what's happening
this is what's currently going on um and this is
like debunked or untrue but it doesn't help that
elon tweets about it but at least he's not going
on interviews yet knock on wood talking about
it because it'll be way worse i think everyone
in the millennials and the people in the
tech community and everyone sort of that we
are talking about is on twitter whereas
the people that would it would really
bother would be people that watch cable television
and so as long as they're not really involved in
all the mess that's okay but i mean the price did
drop significantly by the way what where's the
price now we've been on this so as we speak at
35 853 okay so yeah i want to get your thoughts
so um you know we're diving into a bear market
um there could be i don't know i thought i thought
the bull market was going to go through summer
and so i don't actually think so i think it's a
huge dip um and i think we rally after this slowly
i it'd be interesting dynamic if at the bitcoin
miami conference and also consensus which is the
the last week of may just the attitude in the
air because i think they're you know hoping for
a different sort of situation maybe like a 70k
bitcoin but i don't think it's a bear market
yet but i think we will have one yeah no i'm with
you i think that um the pr this dip is pretty wild
you know it was expected a lot of people were
expecting this you know people were saying we're
gonna get a 50 correction um and so the what
i've what i think what i've heard what seems
to be a common kind of agreement here is that
we're going to have this crazy dip and then
one last shoot to the moon basically um people
are still yeah fingers crossed people are still
hoping for 100k this year um why not we're not
even yeah you're not halfway through yeah it's
it's still may it's still very early i think it's
actually healthy though because it the market and
just the atmosphere was getting crazy and i think
that everyone needs like a cold shower like a cold
bucket of water thrown on them and hopefully
everyone can like relax a little bit or like
sober up from the hysteria that was happening
because it was absolutely bad [ __ ] for
for periods of time yeah i think everybody needs
humbling a bit you know with those damn laser eyes
the community just needs to chill we need humbling
of it get humbled yeah and i i'm humbled right now
too because uh yeah i was you know i've obviously
been buying but then was buying on the way up too
just because just it was so that i was like oh my
gosh i throw all my like free cat i can't even buy
most of this dip because i don't even have any
like capital like throw into it like i don't
know what to do so um anyway yeah i think it's
healthy i think i'm very you know grateful for
a correction it's a great opportunity to buy and i
don't think this is the end of the 2021 cycle but
you know if you've been in this space any period
of time you know these are four-year cycles that
this obviously happens on yeah for sure um okay
so just about you i want to know um so you're
doing an amazing job with try lolly um you're an
absolute pr marketing where's like i think you're
incredible um what's your goal like what's your
overall kind of dream personally or for lolly or
possibly um god that's so hard i because
part of it is with lolly i do want to see
the lolly op on every person's phone eventually
also the app is sort of live for thousands of
people but it's rolling out to thousands of more
at the end of the month so be fully live across
you know the united states everyone can have the
ability to own bitcoin that really is something
that makes me happy and really the while while the
price and obviously i was interested in bitcoin
because it was you know i was young and wanted
to make money the real technology behind it and
what it can do and what cryptocurrency can do for
millions of people around the world is something
that really resonates with me and so i've been
writing a lot of op-eds but i would like to do
i would probably really like to start a non-profit
eventually if i was successful and didn't really
need money to help sort of the causes that i'm
very passionate about and so i think there's a
lot of communities out there in the united states
that i would start with first because i think a
lot of people look outside of the united states
sometimes to go help when there's a lot of people
hurting within yeah right now and so charity
starts at home as they say grows at home it starts
with yourself sort of your family and your friends
and helping and loving the people that are hard to
love you know first and then reaching out from
there and helping other communities so there's
a lot of places i just heard about the indigenous
pop population in the united states that is really
sort of forgotten about here there's places
like flint michigan um in the united states
that still don't have great water you know
there's a lot of places in the united states
that are not mostly the cities are really
hurting so i'd like to do something where
i could potentially give back to other people and
eventually expand out outside the united states um
if that was if i had the time to do it but
um i also would love to live on a beach too
i want a short house like my grandmother's
shore house that i'm in right now but um
that's that's hopefully when uh lolly
ipos well keep stacking their sats yeah
so where can people find you how can everyone stay
up to date with you yes you can follow me at the
name listed below at aubrey strobel and then i
am you know we follow the twitter account too
because we put a lot of hard work into those
tweets so follow at triloli and then download
lolly lolly.com and yeah i'm mostly on uh twitter
but i i saw that you also you hit like 10k on
instagram recently and then i just hit 10k and i
was like i've done you've actually like built up
a like a following there and i need to like try to
build some following um on my personal account for
bitcoin but we also have a great instagram account
for lolly which is what i said earlier about the
meme review and so if you're into bitcoin memes
go over to instagram if only for the memes and
follow lolly there that's great aubrey thank
you so much it's been so good talking to you
i find this whole topic fascinating i think
you're doing such an incredible job with tri lolly
um so thank you so much for coming on thank you so
much for having me this is great absolute pleasure
and guys don't forget to tune in next week because
it's great as always we'll see you then bye